this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show where america hangs
out to have a conversation about your
money
and your life i'm john deloney joined
here by best-selling author
international sensation and good friend
anthony o'neil and we are taking your
calls about your money
about your life about the things that
are going on inside and outside of your
home
and your heart and your mind and in your
checking account anthony
how are we doing good man about yourself
we're doing all right so
as uh well we're taking your calls
triple at eight two five five two two
five it usually helps to uh
give the the number here um
anthony how's your week month year been
going yeah it's been a little rough bro
but you know
i'm getting through it man you know we
are uh fighting through doing some
things and
but uh just grateful to be here man you
know yeah just grateful to be walking
grateful for another day to uh get up
and do god's work and do what i'm
assigned to do man
i've had a similar it's it's been a
rough
couple of a couple of weeks yeah yeah um
what's a what's a go-to thing and i
realize that there's
millions of people listening to this i'm
just asking you as a buddy like
what's a go-to thing for you when things
get heavy
and when things are hand
getting that kicking that leg out of bed
in the morning gets tough yeah yeah
i think for me man i honestly uh just
disconnect you know some people may say
like you
as a therapist or a counselor may say
that's unhealthy but for me
i disconnect so i get off social media i
get off of the cell phones i don't
respond to text messages i don't respond
to people
i just get in my own little private
little prayer closet and just spend some
time
in the dark breathing meditating
uh reading something either spiritual or
inspirational
just to reset my brain that's that's
super healthy
yeah yeah you know i mean and so that's
what i do
you know and it works well for me uh and
then honest and then honestly bro then
i'm truthful throughout the day if i
don't if i'm not having a great day
you know people walk by like man how are
you hey not doing so great but i'll be
all right
you know in the past but how are you i'm
doing good how about yourself when
really i'm doing bad
or really i'm not feeling feeling the
best but i i should be able to be honest
and still be productive still have a
smile on my face and still be good
so that's one thing that i do man i love
that that's that's living an authentic
life right
yeah absolutely yeah i mean because
before
i used to try to cover it all up and i
think covering it up is unhealthy
yeah it shows exactly it shuts it down
right that's that's that's
that's you depress it right yeah yeah i
mean
for me it's just like hey let's just be
real hey yo you're not having a great
week you're not having a great day
but i can still be respectful i can
still smile i can still be honest
um get yourself done right yeah show up
and get the job done and go home and
play with my little girl raven and you
know run around with her and still
be decompressing what's going on and
talking through it but really uh for me
man i connect with my
my mentor my therapist and my spiritual
leader man just to get me back focused
because what we do as a living bro
we got to be on all the time you know we
are expected to be on all the time
and so um sometimes when i'm home i just
i just disconnected so i can be on what
i have to be on
i think that idea man like if you were
to ask me the same thing i'd say this
like
you gotta withdrawal and you got to find
solitude and then you've got to
reach out to other people right you have
to there's two things man you gotta
and like your text message yesterday
morning i was like man that was
i appreciate that bro i was honestly in
my therapy um
talking to my therapist and right in the
middle of that you know i get your text
message right around like 8 15 8 30.
turn your turn your cell phone off
during counseling man
no i mean i didn't read until after
counseling okay you know but when i got
in the car
you know i was like oh man that's what's
up man so i i appreciate that
um because you know she was just asking
me how am i and i was just being honest
with her
um and so to get in my car to see your
text message bro that that was just good
you know that's
that's important too when you are going
through make sure you're connected
to healthy friends who know how to speak
into your life
that can help you push forward it's
become
incredibly important to me after losing
several people i care about over the
last few years
yeah if a name pops into my head
stop what you're doing make a phone call
i need to do that if a name pops into my
head
especially someone hadn't thought of in
a while yeah i'm gonna stop what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna send a text message
i'm gonna shoot an email too write a
card too
you can never tell somebody that they're
loved enough
you know that that's pretty that's
pretty good for those of y'all listening
right now to the millions
millions of people listening right now
whatever name just popped up in your
head right now
connect man i think you need to send him
a text message
um give them a call send them an email
send them a dm
and some of you listen to them you're
going to reach out and say i'm sorry
yes right so that's going good you're
going to reach out and say you're sorry
absolutely all right let's uh let's go
to the phone here let's go to haley in
kansas city
let's see here haley what's going on
hi um how are you guys trying to save me
talking to you guys
we're excited to be talking to you so
what's up how can we help
um so i'm actually about two and a half
hours away from kansas city i
currently am self-employed i'm a hair
stylist in manhattan kansas if you know
where kansas state university is
um and my question is
i've kind of been struggling with if i
should
remain self-employed and if that's like
kind of selfish of me or if i should go
back to be an employee
um quick background i'll try to keep it
brief
i currently drive about an hour and 45
minutes to work
my husband and i moved back to his
hometown in north central
rural kansas in the fall
that's highway driving not like city
traffic driving
and i've been self-employed one year
survives covered my
business done really well and i have an
opportunity to maybe buy
a salon space where we live
we would be taking out a small business
loan to do so
we're debt free we're building up our
emergency fund
again post coded i would probably take a
wage cut if
i went back to working for someone up
there i have a better chance of
maintaining my
income staying self-employed but then
we'd have the small business loan to pay
off on this
long-term location so why does it have
to be either or right now
well um could it be something that
you're in my league
that you earned and you built up over
time
it could so i find another i'm
in a year lease in my current studio so
i'll be commuting until december
basically but um it definitely kind of
takes a toll being away
during the week we don't have kids or
anything but
i have dogs and um you have a husband
i guess i've i have a husband too
i've got dogs and he knows
but um yeah i just i know i don't want
to be commuting
um almost two hours one way
um four days a week
to come next year so i want to be closer
to home but
just trying to decide i guess what the
smartest thing to do is
and if that means kind of sacrificing my
self-employment for a few years or
yeah i i think you've made your decision
you want to stay at home i think it's
how you're going to get there
never in a million years did you take
out a small business loan
and so and you've already signed a lease
so you're committed to this thing
through december
so what i would do is look at ways you
guys can sock away money
you guys can pack and suck away money i
think you can probably open your own
business there
or you can do both it's when we get into
this either or thinking but you've made
your decision up you're going to move in
you're going to move back closer to home
with your husband work closer to home
with your husband
figure out to make it work and do not
take out a loan for god's sake don't
take out a loan
this is the ramsay show
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
so
this is the ramsey show triple eight
eight two five five two two five i'm
john delony joined here with
best-selling author ramsey personality
anthony o'neil and we're taking your
calls on your money
and on your life whatever's going on we
are here to help triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to
jessica in new orleans jessica what's
going on
hey guys what's going on it's such a
pleasure to speak to you both
anthony it's just amazing i recently
bought your debt free degree for a
friend of mine because she really could
use your wisdom
but i'm calling about my own situation
today
i recently decided to walk away from a
job of 14 years
and dropped my family income by about a
hundred thousand dollars so i wanted to
tell you kind of what i have and
what you think i should do so i do have
about 230 000
in my 403 b but i'll have to decide
where that's going to go where should i
roll that to
i have 75 in cash in savings
which is more than my six month
emergency fund
i owe 143 on my mortgage
but i also have the money on hand
excluding the 75
but i can just go ahead and pay that
through the end of the year because i'd
really like to just take some time off
and enjoy my family
and i'm kind of just wondering what do
you guys think what should i do i have
no debt other than my home our cars are
paid for we have no college loans that's
paid for
i have a master's my husband he's been
working part-time
i've let my income allowed him to do so
we've always been very supportive
when the other needs a break or needs a
change and this time it's my
time for the change and the break so
what are your thoughts so jessica why
did you walk away from the job
um so i'm a nurse and i grew within the
organization
and went into administration and got to
the point where
i felt there was nothing more i could do
for my team i really loved my team
but it was just getting difficult to
work within that arena
in administration so i decided to
take a step back and think about
something that's going to bring me joy
and find what that is and take my time
to find it okay okay cool
and so i believe you're in a healthy
place right now okay i think that
with you being 100 debt free i would
definitely jump on the phone with one of
our smart
vested pros so we can get your um
your 230 000 rolled over into
a uh an ira and so that way i would
definitely jump on the phone with them
like today to get that process started
and then from there i think uh you and
your family
need to sit down and now are you married
correct
i am what's your household income now
about 40 000 my husband works part-time
but again
we're we're pretty well we've made good
financial decisions up until now
so i'm i'm not going to be able to
continue
uh mortgage payments about 1200 i've
been i've paid 20 000 on it since
november i've really been attacking it
okay trying to get it completely paid
for but of course i'm gonna pause
since i'm leaving my job yeah so i mean
you're in a good place i think
um i don't have a problem with you
taking off the rest of the rest of the
year
now here's my only thing um is 230 000
all you all have invested into your
retirement accounts
no that's just my portion my husband has
probably 250.
okay okay cool so you all are in a
healthy place i think what you got to do
is really
sit down and come up with a game plan
for what's
happening moving forward okay i'm gonna
take the next six months off
spend some time with the family uh but
next year
january of 2022 this is what i want to
do this is where i'm going to go
um or whatever you all plan you're in a
healthy place now you don't have any
debt
the only debt that you have is your
mortgage and that's okay and your
mortgage payment is only twelve hundred
dollars a month and you have the cash
to take care of that i think once you
start getting below your six months
reserve
uh you you wanna make sure you don't go
there uh so i would definitely plan on
making sure that you
have a game plan uh moving forward
within the next six months i don't know
if i'll take off a whole year jessica
uh that's just my personal opinion and
so i need to watch doing that kind of
stuff but i'm saying for you
uh sit down have a conversation with
your family
and figure out what's best for your
family moving forward
but i would definitely look at a game
plan within the next six months
and jessica i spoke to a high-level exec
this morning who is returning from a
leave
and he said something profound he said
the first few weeks
were magic i got to breathe i got to
look at my kids in the eye i got to
watch them i got to have breakfast with
them
it was and then he said about week three
four and five i started getting really
itchy
and this time off became as much of a
burden
as the time was that was at work right
and so i had to
begin reaching out to folks i had to
start planning i had to start
solving making solving problems and and
and moving forward and so be intentional
about the time you take off
yeah and structure that in some shape
form or fashion just this
dream of doing nothing is so good in a
vacation it's so good for a short time
but we're not designed to do nothing and
that could end up becoming a burden too
yes no i absolutely get that my days are
well
planned it's time to focus on me for a
while i think
these last 14 years have just taken a
toll on me especially the last three
have just really hit my health so i
definitely have some
big focus on that during this time but i
agree i have to stay busy
but i have realized those aha moments
where it's like oh my i look at my watch
and there's no calendar appointment
whatsoever and that is priceless
it will be priceless and after you've
had a chance to breathe it will
start to slowly creep it'll it'll create
some anxiety in your soul
right yeah um because we have that
purpose
and in in staying busy i don't hear me
say you got to stay busy
you just have to be intentional with
purpose right
and that may mean i'm intentionally
going to take a nap every day for the
next two months
right i am intentionally going to go
exercise i'm intentionally going to use
my nursing skills to go volunteer
i'm intentionally going to get out there
and do some things but i'm not going to
be held to a clock i'm not going to be
held to
you know all these tps reports that i
got to get turned in all the time i'm
not going to be held to that kind of
stuff right
yeah the administrative world man can
take your
soul from you uh anthony the the hardest
thing i've
of working with professors who then you
know become
you know associate deans and they become
deans most people
got into the field of teaching or the
field of nursing because they
love that engagement with the student or
with the patient
and then they're so good at it
unfortunately
the the reward for being so good is
let's take you away from that and give
you a different type of job
yeah right yeah and then you're good at
that let's take you even further away
and now you are managing
light bills and you're managing budgets
and structures and you're so far away
from that thing you love to do
right yeah yeah and so man there's an
administrative burden that that comes
with that
have you ever had a job in your life
anthony that you
were so good at they started you know as
the reward was we're gonna move you
further and further away from it
i'm trying to think like in ministry
right when you're really good at working
with young people then it's like well we
need to get him on a stage and then you
do well on a stage he's like well we
need to get him into some administrative
roles
or maybe not maybe you've just stayed
plugged in yeah i mean all of my jobs uh
in the past
when i did really really well i know
they kept me they left you alone yeah
no we can't afford to have him leave
that that particular area
uh which is why i think sometimes
transitioning jobs are difficult because
the employer is like well no you're the
best in that position so we need you in
that position
but that means you never have to grow
and everything exactly exactly okay so
i've never been in our position
huh that's a that's a common experience
she has
that i hear from administrators who are
in healthcare
and god bless the nurses man what a year
they've had yeah right
yeah the hospital administrators how are
we going to pay our bills are we going
to serve all these people
i can just imagine and good for her for
setting her family up in a situation
where
he can actually take a break a young
couple with five thousand dollars cash
only a hundred forty three thousand
dollars on their mortgage with
close to five hundred thousand dollars
in retirement um that that's
that's a healthy vibrant young couple
she
she's worked hard to where she can take
a few months off
and just enjoy her family i mean and i
think that's good man
it's good just to regroup absolutely
figure out what's next
everyone needs a couple of months off
just to relax
do we everyone hey you and me were going
to dave with that one i liked it
[Laughter]
i like it oh we may not get that signed
off but yeah
pretty sure dave's going to say hey
appreciate the email guys y'all get back
tomorrow
i love it this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show i'm john
deloney joined here with best-selling
author anthony o'neil
we're taking your calls on money and
life let's go to area
in washington d.c what is going on
hello i'm really glad that i made it to
the
dave ramsey show um i'm a first time
home buyer me and my husband are
planning
for our very first home we're looking in
north virginia region
and you know with the market being so
crazy right now i'm just kind of looking
for
a little bit more advice of what we
should do because
we just see that you know prices for the
homes are really shooting up
everyone is waving contingencies all the
buyers are lining up and
overpaying for the house on average
around fifty thousand dollars in a home
so i'm really a little bit apprehensive
of should we kind of wait it out and see
what happens to the market in the future
and maybe go ahead with our plan
next year or what should we do
well um where are you currently right
now in the baby steps
uh i'm just recently started uh watching
and i'm familiar with the baby steps um
so our
income together uh yearly income is
around 200k
uh we have like 20 000 in debt
and we have saved like 100k for like
10 down payment and the closing cost
um but yeah we don't have really
emergency funds it's just kind of
really be saving for the home yeah so we
haven't really started on the steps
let's say
honestly all right cool so no you're not
ready to purchase a home yet
okay um okay now let me tell you this
though
you're not far away from it at all to be
honest
um how much of a home do you want to
purchase for an example give me how much
of a home are you looking at purchasing
so we were starting looking around like
600 to 700
and now we're at the point that we have
to kind of stretch it out if we really
want to jump into this
market train okay so you're looking at
600k
home all right um hold on one minute i'm
just doing my math on my calculator
right here i'm not as quick as dave
uh and so here's the thing so check this
out this is what i would do if i was in
your shoes i would pause and wait till
next year
okay and let me tell you why i want you
to be debt free will it fully
with a fully funded emergency fund
before you even consider a home
you'll be a stronger buyer at that time
so what i would do is i'll take 20
000 out of you all's money today and go
pay off all of
my debt all right that's going to bring
you down to 80
000 okay that's gonna bring you down to
80
000 all right then what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna look at three months of
expenses because it sounds like you all
are in a good
stable job situation so you probably
need about
25 let's say about 25 25
thousand dollars uh to have for a fully
funded emergency fund right
so that leaves you with fifty five
thousand dollars
left in your account to go towards a
down payment to get a six hundred
thousand dollar home
you're going to need right around 120
000
for a 20 down payment that's a great way
to get in to avoid a pmi
so what i teach is you have the bare
minimum
of 10 to 20 so you're gonna need a bare
minimum
of about ninety thousand to a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars to get into
a home
with you all's income you can be debt
free have a fully funded emergency fund
and have twenty percent by this time
next year
now you're in a healthier place to
purchase a home
okay you have no debt if something
happened when you moved into the home
at least you have an emergency fund for
that the game plan that you have right
now
if you go out there and you purchase a
home and spend way more money than what
the house is actually worth
you're still gonna have twenty thousand
dollars in debt and
you're gonna spend all your money on
your down payment you don't even have an
emergency fund
but you make twenty thousand dollars
gross uh you know a month
so that sounds good but no i want you to
be safe so my recommendation is
push off see what the market is going to
do over the next 12 months
while you're waiting for the next 12
months go ahead go ahead
transfer that money pay off your debt
today transfer
25 30 000 over to a separate savings
account
a money market account that is simply
just for emergencies only that's going
to leave you about 50 to 55 000
then you and your husband sit down and
figure out okay cool
bae how do we get the the how do we get
up to 120
within the next 12 months what do we
need to do within our budget
to be a strong candidate to purchase a
home so that's my two cents on on that
and i think right now you're in a great
position you're not
unhealthy uh you're not you're not
looking bad
i'm just saying let's just reposition
some things so we can be in
even in a better place within the next
12
i i this is a great question man yeah
and anyone who tells you well
it's about to you don't know yeah yeah
you really don't
but here's the beauty when you have a
fully funded emergency fund when you put
20
down and the market come on bro does
what it's going to do
which is to go up and down listen you
don't lose sleep right
you go oh that sucks but you're in the
house that you want
yeah and then you go to the next day and
the next day the next day it's when
you're leveraged out you're barely
making that payment you had a 600 000
budget and then you buy a 700 000
house because you had to bid up on it
and now you've gotten underwater right
yeah
and i think right now man right now the
market is a seller's market
by far like if it's i mean people are
spending
right here in our own city uh it's a
banana it's about 20
30 40 000 over what they're asking for
nine times out of ten this is over what
the house is actually worth
and so if you are financing a home it's
gonna be
real hard for you to get into the home
if you don't have the money down
right you know and so what i'm saying is
um dude i'm not saying do not
not buy what i'm saying is just make
sure you have your foundation
and you have some cash so you can get
into the home that you really desire but
for me i'm not spending
thirty thousand forty thousand dollars
on that more than what the house is
actually worth now we actually waited
nine months and we kept
absolutely in offers putting offers
getting rejected and then finally we
found the right place yeah always go to
melody in raleigh north carolina melody
what's up
hi thank you for taking my call how are
you guys we are so so good thanks for
calling
how can we help alrighty so i
am 19 years old i started listening to
dave ramsey when i was 16
right before i got my first job and he
has really helped you know
keep me from making a lot of young dumb
people decisions
um right now i currently make with my
current job around eleven hundred
dollars a month
i have about a twenty three hundred
dollar
um cash savings and emergency fund
and just side savings my question is
do you guys think that i should be
investing or do you think it would be a
good idea to continue to just save
up into my savings uh
do you you so you're living at home with
your parents right now right
yeah i'm currently in school and they
allow me to live at home cool you're 19.
i like that
i'm cool with that i was about to say
something else but i like that you're in
school
1100 income we are 100 debt free we
don't have any credit cards no car loans
student loans no student loans no
loans no boyfriend loans
yeah yeah none whatsoever i bought my
car outright
i saved up for that um and i pay for my
school
on a monthly it gets you know drafted
from my account sixty dollars a month
cool great talk to me about school
you're on a 100 scholarship so we don't
need any more books we don't need
dorm room food we don't need nothing
paid for for college to complete college
100 debt free um
i am not on a scholarship i'm through
actually an online course
going through a veterinary technician
program
to advance to hopefully a doctor
down the line i'm fortunate enough that
you know in the field that i work in a
lot of the
vet techs have gone through that program
and they've been giving me
their old books that they no longer need
anymore cool but so
it's not a guarantee that you will be
able to
pay cash it sounds like or you'll be
able to get the
funds moving forward to pay for college
meaning that you may have to come up and
provide some cash
or get some scholarships in the
foreseeable future correct
correct yeah so i don't want you to
invest at all right now
the number one investment you can do
melody is invest into yourself
and what i want you to do is invest into
yourself and make sure that you graduate
100 debt free
so this way when you actually graduate
college
you walk across the street the stage
ahead of your peers
you walk across the stage debt-free
little money in your account
and you can enjoy your future so do not
invest the money into stocks
none of that invest the money into
yourself save it until you
until you need to use it to go towards
your college listen to me america it's
not worth it
it's not worth it don't try and jump to
get compound interest
and you're racking up debt avoid debt
then let's talk about
how we get this bag which is how do we
make some more money this is anthony
o'neil
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsay show i'm john
delony joined here by best-selling
author
anthony o'neil and we're taking your
calls on money
and life let's go to austin in sumner
illinois austin what's going on brother
um not too much i've just got a few
questions for you guys
bring him on brother how can we help
okay
well um i'm 13 and i
start i'm starting my own i'm certainly
a little business it's called akw
farms um i'm
i'm going to be selling goat smoke this
summer be
um honey i right now i make shows and
stuff i do a lot of woods
wood crafts and stuff and i was just
wondering
how much money i need to be putting back
into the business
and when i can start taking money out
for me austin
you just made my whole day brother you
are awesome
awesome also how long how long have you
uh been uh
talking about this and doing it
um i've been talking about it for about
two to three years i actually
started it you could say i started about
two years ago
when i got goats but i really started
selling stuff
last year at the farmer's market i make
shelves out of pallet boards
wow okay all right that's so cool
awesome well here's the thing man
uh what i'm gonna do is because there's
so much we can we can walk through this
austin um and i just love your heart
behind it so what i'm gonna do is uh
when we get off the phone with you
i'm going to have kelly send you have
your mom or dad
say stand by so they can give you so
they can give kelly your address because
i'm going to send you a copy of my
toolbox kit
my teen entrepreneurial toolbox kit
uh where i'm going to literally walk you
through the whole process so when you
get this kit young man
i want you to um read it read it with
your parents
and it's gonna teach you your sales
pitch it's gonna teach you how to make a
business budget and i'm gonna even teach
you exactly how should you be allocating
your funds
uh the first thing is going to really
figure out okay what does it cost you to
run the business
okay you got to buy materials you got to
buy products
so you got to put money back into the
business so we need to identify
how much do you need to put back in
there and then from there then yes what
are you going to be paying yourself what
are you going to be putting into your
checking account into your savings
account
but i think right now the main thing is
that you will need to sit down with your
parents and figure out
how much money do i need every month
to keep producing what you're producing
have you all even talked about that
already
um well
kinda yeah i've got luckily for me i can
get um pallets for free my dad works for
ups and whenever they're done with the
loading he can just pick up pallets and
we have a bunch of stockpiles
so you've got a raw materials material
just sitting there that's fantastic
yeah what other um tools do you need
real quick
um austin um
uh i've got a palette buster which my
dad was one of them
before so he appears that i can use it
um i mean i use a circular saw a jigsaw
hammer nails and usually some hooks
okay so it sounds like it sounds like
your parents are already setting you up
to win
so the income that you would need to put
back into the company and then the
income you would use to pay yourself
may be a little different uh depending
upon it sounds like your father can get
you the tools and the material for free
so you may be looking at 90 80 of your
um
your income that you make will go into
you into your future
and maybe 10 or 20 would go back to your
father for helping him get the materials
or
helping your father get some materials
uh for you down the road so
i'm loving it young man let me ask you
this question that's off subject
and again i want you to stay on the line
and kelly's going to get your address uh
to send you a copy of my teen
entrepreneur toolbox kit but what are
you going to do with all this money
like when you start making this money
how are you going to spend it
well um there's a few things is
i'm like i said i i'm buying the cash in
with some of my money i already have
saved up from
because i do 4-h and stuff like that so
i have money saved up from the options
so i'm going to be buying part of a cow
me and my parents are going to go in on
it all together
that's what i'm talking about
and one of the big things i'm wanting is
i'm saving up for a 22
mag rifle and a full four-wheeler
yeah this dude is what's up this man
just said i'm saving for a gun and a
four-wheeler that sounds like a bright
kid
uh to me okay no it was a cow in a 22
in a four-wheeler you
are my hero austin this
is unique this is interesting hey man
i'm rooting for you i am celebrating you
austin
uh stay on the line man kelly will get
your address she'll send you that teen
entrepreneur toolbox kid
uh when you get the cow when you get the
rifle when you get the four-wheeler man
send me and john a picture of that
uh so we can celebrate with you man if
you guys would like to see it
before i um well not before but when i
before i get to send you guys pictures
you can subscribe to my youtube channel
it's akw
farms oh hey listen to this number one
brother knows how to push his name and
hey you are better than i am at that so
well done
and yes we will check out your website
tell us one more time
akw farms my initials akw
farms good folks go to that website get
yourself some honey and some goat milk
from a 13 year old entrepreneur who's
put it together and all he wants america
is a cow and a 22 and a four wheeler
hey help him out i am not mad at him at
all man that's hey he could have said
xbox and what good for that kid that
makes
man he just made everything better in my
day all right let's go to stephanie in
st paul stephanie what's going on hi
thanks for taking my call yeah what's up
um
so my question is around paying down our
house versus investing so i'm
31 years old and getting married in june
my fiance
thank you um my fiance is 34 and we're
both doing really well
financially we're going to make about
240 combined
um and once we get married we won't have
any debt after we pass
his car which is about 19 um thousand
and the only debt left will be on the
house which we just refinanced
to a 15 year with a lower interest rate
um i'm selling my house too so we're
going to get income from that
we both have emergency like two to three
months of emergency fund
in cash and then i'm also investing uh
14
in my 401k um he was doing about six
and then we started doing about five
grand into um stock health accounts and
bonds
so my question is we live in minnesota
but we're hoping to move closer to
family
in the next few years um my family's in
illinois and his
in michigan um so we're wondering since
we don't know if we're going to be here
long term
should we still try to be trying to
pay off this house that we're going to
be in as fast as possible
or should we be saving that cash in the
bank or
investing into bonds or something that
we can pull out of
um when we're ready to make another
down payment for the maybe forever home
um two things why are you investing 14
of your 401k are they matching you your
14
yeah they actually match um uh
it's an 8 okay so do you have a
uh do you have a roth ira outside of
your 401ks
um yes yep yep
so that's what i'm contributing sorry
between the both of them i'm doing
fourteen percent oh okay okay
okay so it sounds like you're doing
eight percent over there the 401k then
you're investing the rest over there
okay cool let's get that up to 15
there's one more percent um okay uh
that's that and then two
uh my answer is going to be yes continue
focusing on the house here's why because
you said
possibly you said possibly if you knew
for sure
we're going to be going in the next two
years i would say just go ahead and make
the mortgage payments but you cannot go
wrong because what if life changes
and you all decide to stay there well at
least you are ahead of the game
and here's the thing let's say if you go
the next two years boom
you're gonna get the money back you know
it's gonna come back to you because
you're gonna sell the home and you're
gonna make some more money on it with
profit
um i'm not in the bonds you know i'm i'm
in the mutual funds i'm not into single
stocks
um i'm into just making sure that i'm
investing in in a good solid
uh way and so for me if i'm in your
shoes
i'm going to keep attacking the house
because that's the best investment and
if i sell it
i'll get that money back and then some
uh when it comes to
equity in the house so that's what i
would recommend for you but
great great job congrats on getting
married let's go ahead and get that debt
paid off though because you ain't debt
free yet
so if you all have two to three months
in your emergency fund right now
use that money pay off your debt restock
up the emergency fund
then start going on baby steps four
through seven
that's a couple that's going to get
married and be able to
sleep the whole night through out of the
gate this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money
i am john deloney and joined with me
here as a co-host is ramsey personality
best-selling author
and host of the table with anthony
o'neill mr anthony o'neil himself
we're taking your calls on life and
money triple eight eight two five five
two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five let's go to miguel
in las vegas miguel what's going on
hey john anthony thank you for taking my
call and my question is about uh
if i can afford to put an emergency fund
for my mother
without asking my brother for help he's
not in the best
money situation and my mom has no
insurance
at all so i have to take care of her no
income
and i can give you some numbers and see
if i can
do it without my brother's health okay
before you get to that tell me what
situation with your mom she has no
insurance is she needing to move in with
you is she struggling she got health
issues
she's she's with me she's living with me
uh her status in this country is not
quite legal yet we've been battling it
for a while and
i've been taking care of her and i don't
know for how long
this is going to be she's 78 she's in a
good health condition it's just that we
test the positive or discovery not too
long ago
she did with me and that's when it hit
me that
i needed to have an emergency fund for
her
okay besides mine that's wise brother
good for you
all right so start uh start going with
the numbers here and anthony will help
you out
okay so uh our income this is my wife
and mine
it's about 135
i got a debt of about 60 000 on a rental
property
my savings are about 185
and after putting my emergency fund
together
i'll be left with 164. i could probably
sell the rental property it's about
worth
maybe 240 but the money for the
emergency plant
or i can pay it off uh i don't know
which way to go
and but i also got two kids that are
going to be going college
probably in the next four years so i
also got that on top
yeah so let me get this straight you
make 135 000 a year you have 60 000
in a rental property um and
you have 185 000 in your savings correct
correct yeah so why would you not
just pay off your rental property i
don't think you need
any more money uh set aside for an
emergency for your for your mom
and and i want to say this in respectful
ways sounds like what you're trying to
do is just prepare
if something was to happen to your
mother which i think is
wise but if you have a hundred thousand
dollars sitting here savings account
that's more than enough to properly um
you know bury your mom if something was
to happen
uh down the road but or let's just say
something is going to the hospital
you have a good nest egg to
get your mama into the er if something
was to happen even worse
you know you have enough money so i
wouldn't say set aside more money
i would just focus on clearing out that
60 000
in debt and if you did that that would
put you right at about
125 uh thousand dollars
if you paid off yeah the the rental
property you still got a good nest egg
and then i was just go in the head how
old are your kids
uh one is 16 okay and the other one is
14.
yeah so what i'll do is i'll go ahead
and just purchase my book off of amazon
and go to my website
anthonyniel.com and get the debt-free
degree
and start teaching your kids how they're
going to go to school 100 debt-free
but i think you have more than a month
more than enough
uh money in your nest egg for you
your family and your mother uh
i don't think you need any more money
set aside
for a nest egg for your mother i think
you need to pay off the rental property
and go ahead and start stacking up some
more money and get prepared for college
if she have any
i guess with her immigration status
there is no social security and there's
no way to go out on exchange and get
health insurances there
no definitely not that's why i am fully
responsible 100 for her any any
emergency bills and
any hospital bills and any that that is
going to be towards her it's mine yeah
and i mean six figures is more than
enough for that an emergency
i would definitely say um well i mean a
hospital bill can
be a million dollars and at that point
it's a million dollars right yeah but i
mean
for him to save you're not gonna have a
million dollars in a checking account
just in case something happens someday
right and so this i think the thing is
continue fighting the fight
you know on the legal side um and then
the six figures i mean
there's pretty much nothing else that he
could possibly do right now right now
yeah um and i think you're doing a great
job bro i think right now
focus on lowering your expenses lowering
your kids expenses
uh so that way if something was to
happen you have you have more than
enough money
to go towards your mother if something
was to happen okay so keep the rental
and just pay it off
i mean right it's up to you do you like
being a landlord yeah if you like being
a landlord i would pay it off
you know i always i always go back to
what dave says if i had 240 000 would i
go buy that house
maybe not but in the i look towards my
kids future maybe
i have no problem whatsoever with the
land uh being a landlord
it's great and it's paying a lot by
itself but i'll go ahead and pay it off
yeah i mean that's what i wanted to hear
i i think you just paid off
you know if i'm in your shoes again this
is not a dave ramsey
uh opinion it's not a john de lon's
depends on anthony's opinion i like what
you just said
uh i'm going to pay off the mortgage so
i can pass that down to my kids to
produce
income for my kids down the road and so
that's how
i personally think um i know dave for an
example whatever rental properties
whatever properties he
he purchases he doesn't sell them he
will not sell them
he's gonna keep him in a family for him
for his kids for his grandkids down the
road
uh but again if you are not happy being
the landlord then yeah go get the money
and have that money sitting there uh but
for me brah
i'm i'm gonna keep it and uh keep that
and give it to my kids and let them
decide if they want to sell it down the
road
i'm thinking generational wealth i'm
thinking legacy um
i'm thinking how do i help my kids
produce and come down the road that's
what i'm thinking miguel and i think
this is a good opportunity for you
to be in position to pass something down
to your kids that is lucrative for them
uh down the road tell me about your
relationship with your brother you
mentioned you don't want to ask him for
money
well he's not in the best position
to to be contributing with the he you
know he's been struggling too
okay and i think i'm going to push him
to get to you guys a little more
uh to your show and he's not
in a great decision you know i have a
good relation with him i just don't want
to put that very in on him as well so i
think
he won the lottery when he got miguel as
a brother
because miguel you are a guy that takes
care of your family you're a guy that's
got your financial house in order
your god's thinking about his kids and
you're a guy that's thinking about the
heart
and the potential shame out of your
brother to the point that you even want
to keep him out of that
i think he would benefit greatly from
you sitting down with him and saying hey
listen this is embarrassing for brothers
to talk about there's no shame here
there's no
no fighting here i need to let you know
that here's the decisions me and my
family have made that have set us up in
this way
and now we're talking about do we sell
our other house to help out mom or do we
hang on to it right that's a different
conversation then
mom may you know have to go into a
special living situation
because we can't afford to keep her and
then you can give him the tools send him
our way we'll get him
the the info that he needs and now
you're talking about changing the entire
family system there brother that's
awesome solid this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
have you ever made a dumb decision with
zeros on the end because you didn't do
your research
yeah me too i have
most people make choices based on
feelings or opinions
especially when buying a house but when
it comes to the real estate market
feelings aren't your friend
facts are so check your facts find out
what you can actually
afford research what's trending in home
prices
talk to a reputable real estate agent in
your area
never buy a house without the facts
again text house
to 33789 and get an agent who will help
you make smart decisions
that's house two three three seven
eight nine all right let's go to katie
in tampa florida katie what's going on
hi you guys thank you so much for taking
my call
um so i'm 27 years old
and i am i have no college debt i
just recently paid off my first home
purchase
um and for the last
probably two or three years i've
actually been able to like
max out my retirement account um
so i'm kind of in this position now
where i have
like quite a bit of capital just kind of
sitting in a savings account and i'm not
really sure
like what i'm supposed to be doing with
it um obviously i should be investing it
um and i am i've got probably i've got
like 70 000
in a brokerage account but i'm just kind
of like self-managing right now
in some mutual funds yeah but then i've
also got like
another 60 000 that's just like sitting
in savings accounts and
so i don't know i guess i just wanted to
see what your
opinion was should i be looking at real
estate or
i don't know like what do what do you
guys thought hey katie i
definitely want to sit here and say man
i mean it's not often we meet a 27 year
old that just says
hey yeah i paid off my house and just
flies by it and it says yeah then now
i got this other issue over here i just
want you to i just want to call this out
like hey you are winning
yeah you are you you are thank you guys
so much you are a young queen out here
doing
her thing i know that's probably bad
grammar but it is what it is
uh yeah you know um i do
sales for commission okay yeah i mean i
go hard
yes i love it i love it well here's the
thing um
i definitely want to get that that 70k
in the brokerage account actually with
a an actual financial advisor so what i
would recommend katie is
jumping on the line and sitting down
with the financial one of our financial
advisors
aka a smart vessel pro and so he can
literally or she can literally sit down
with you
and be a teacher along this journey
because right now you need to be taught
how to set yourself up to be a
millionaire
within the next 20 years and with your
wisdom
with your knowledge already with your
talents with
your income you have the capability of
doing
it even before 20 years so i would
encourage you to get with
a financial advisor who has a heart of a
teacher that will sit down with you so
okay
we're going to move this money put this
over here we're going to put this over
there
six thousand dollars cash you need to
have six months
reserved i'm gonna say go ahead and just
stretch yourself to six months
reserved of your bare minimum of your
expenses
that's separate i didn't include that
okay cool so then
uh you keep that so the other part of it
is just sit down and see how can you
properly invest it now
when it comes to the leftover money if
you want to get into real estate
do it you know that's that's great uh
one of the things that i'm looking into
is land you know we can't make any more
land
we can continue building buildings but
i'm looking into how do i purchase land
for my kids kids how can i
purchase this lot of land or purchase
you know a couple of acres over here
and pass it down to my kids or purchase
that so i can build
something on it down the road and then
rent that out down the road so
i think once the first step is sit down
with a financial advisor
start investing into the stock market
mutual funds
in a healthy solid way then extra money
from there
yes start setting aside to where you can
pay cash
for real estate options and i think
that's a great real estate or
a a side business that you may want to
start up
i would definitely look into chrissy
wright and get a copy of her book
business boutique
actually i think her academy is actually
opening up here soon katie
uh so i would definitely look into that
if you want to start a business
that can generate some more income for
you on the side while you do exactly
what you're doing on sales but what are
you selling katie
um i do work site um worksite benefits
specifically like life insurance and
then supplemental health plans as well
gotcha you must be real real good at
this yeah she's selling she's sounding
like hockey
um so if i didn't i mean i've had a
financial advisor in the past
and he my sister used him that's why i
used him
um but he was very young and i kind of
was just
not super um like impressed with i guess
the performance because of his age or
because of his performance
performance okay yeah performance i just
i just didn't like um
i don't know i also i also wanted more
accountability like i wanted to kind of
force myself to kind of learn a little
bit more but
yeah i do think it's a really really
good idea for me to get a financial
advisor
um what's a reasonable um
like i know it goes by percentage of
assets managed is like
one percent reasonable like is one and a
half
high i don't really know i mean i'm not
gonna sit here and say what's reasonable
because i think
it all depends on who you're talking to
you know our financial advisors do not
work for us
and so they have the right to say what
they want to charge but i would
definitely say
they've been through a very hard
process to be a smart vessel pro and so
whatever they're asking for
we know that and we we agree that their
percentage
or their cost is worth their time so i
would definitely just say just just jump
on
go over to daveramsey.com go to
ramsolutions.com
uh type in smartvestor pro and you'll
see one and you're gonna get
five five to six phone calls uh within a
matter of
five minutes of you filling out this
application
uh interview all of them spend some time
ask a lot of questions
ask them you know what are their fees
ask them like hey
will you be willing to teach me will you
be willing to take some time with me and
educate me on this process
um you know and then from there you just
make the best decision upon yourself
but i do know um different financial
advisors charge
different fees but i think everyone is
worth their fee
you just got to feel as if if you
believe that they're worth that fee
and i think i think she brings up a
great point when you're talking about a
financial advisor you're talking about a
counselor
um you're talking about any professional
that you go to
[Music]
you don't owe them anything no
right so if you go to a financial
advisor and you
hear their pitch and you hear their fee
and you feel like they're selling you
some sort of package because that's the
package of the month that they're trying
to offload because it's gonna up there
you smile and walk out the door yeah
with your head held high
yeah and if you go sit down and and
with a counselor for the first time and
they spend more time talking about
themselves and how smart and fancy they
are
and they're telling you what get up and
walk out yeah
right it doesn't it doesn't surprise me
at all katie is both
brilliant and strong and she's um
decisive
i actually shopped around when it came
to fees and i pushed my
um the guy i landed on real hard when it
came to fees
i wanted to know is my are you getting
paid regardless
are you getting paid based on the
quality of your advice i had a lot of
questions about fees
yeah and so it's going to depend on how
much money you got obviously but can
depend on what you want them to do do
you want them to set it and forget it do
you want them to manage that it's all
that stuff goes into the part of that
conversation
but i do katie i love your heart and say
man i sat with somebody they weren't
great i didn't like their performance
and so i didn't feel comfortable i left
good for you yeah
this is your legacy this is your future
talk about counseling this is your
mental health this
is somebody you're giving access into
your soul
yeah be totally comfortable that with
that with that interaction
yeah and they should teach you not
demean you they should
inform you and walk alongside you one of
the questions i ask everybody
like what are your goals what are your
goals i always tell them what do you do
for your family
um what is the portfolio portfolio that
you have for your family
he's like well you know i don't i don't
really want to talk about then i'm going
to walk out the door because
if you don't trust your family with it i
don't think i want it
right and so the person i landed on
actually sent
me their family stuff that's good this
is what my family's in right now
and i said cool put me in that right
because you're gonna trust your money
and your legacy with what you know of
the market
and your kids legacy that's good enough
that's good bro
i don't know man you're trying to sell
me some package good for you kitty that
made my heart feel good
hey hey call smartmaster pro good folks
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
825-5225 this is the ramsay show
let's go out to louisville kentucky and
talk to terrence terrence what's going
on man
okay thank you what's up
yes uh how you guys doing today we're
doing outstanding good man
how can we help hey i was trying to see
miss o'neill i
read your book with my granddaughter and
uh she's very young now she's only 11
years old but
she's motivated to like start you know
doing things now
to to make money i was trying to just
see if you guys could help me brainstorm
on how she could
start raising money now as a young
person oh man that's just a good
question yeah so she's 11 years old
we're trying to figure out how to start
raising money for your granddaughter
uh right now do you and your on the on
the parent side of thing and
grandparents side of thing do you all
have a 529 already open in her name
no uh and i was talking to uh
her parents really not into that type of
stuff
and uh i think she's gonna be out there
flapping unless i do it so i was trying
to see
ways that if i could help her do it on
her own if her parents weren't when
doing financial things
yes so uh terence you can open up a 529
in your daughter's name you will just
need um her social security information
um you wouldn't hear name and social
security so if you can get access to
that you can do that because i have
uh 529's uh my actually my parents
and i have a 529 uh in the name of my uh
nieces and nephews and so you can do
that now and i will go ahead and start
maxing that out as much as possible so
like when she come over your house
uh grandpa's house have her work around
the house and tell her hey i'm gonna put
some money inside of this account for
you
every time you work so that's one thing
that you should do and jump on it right
now
um how how how's her education process
does she seem like she's going to be
smart going into the middle school in
high school year
yeah yeah very very smart she was uh she
was all into that about the good grades
and uh
applying for scholarships and those type
of things so is that so that's one thing
i would tell her
to really do as a as her grandfather
talk to her a lot about a grade say hey
listen
your grades your academics what you do
in middle school and high school will
determine
uh what school you go to and where you
go
and so when she gets into middle school
i would start having a conversation with
her parents but hey let's get her ready
because he read inside of my book that
free degree right around the eighth
grade she can get inside the duke
program
and so she can get inside that program
that's going to open up a lot of
scholarships for her
uh and so i would definitely say focus
on opening up a 529 right now the number
two
make sure that you really have a serious
but fun
uh conversation around her grades making
just making sure that she knows
middle school it starts right here baby
you need all a's
okay you can get one b here but we need
all a's so that way you can go
to her school here's another thing that
has nothing to do with money
and america i want y'all to hear me
because terence asks a great question
um in my book i teach people how to go
from the 7th grade
up into the 12th grade on how to get
into college debt free
everyone says well why start so young
well here's the thing john that i
learned one of my homegirls has a school
here in nashville and in elementary okay
in elementary school she does college
visits for fourth and fifth graders
and i said well why and this is
something that you should do with your
granddaughter
take her on a college visit now why so
young anthony she's only 11 years old
well because young people at that age
they are
impressionable so when they walk around
this big old campus
you can take them to a community college
and they're going to think that they're
just in heaven like oh this is so cool
and so as she grows she's going to say
my granddaddy took me to a college and
granddad i want to go back there
granddaddy or mom and dad i want to do
this i want to go to school i want to do
that
why because of what her grandfather did
when she was 11 years old she puts a
picture of what college actually is in
her head
yes she sees young people walking around
it starts to make sense
yes so so terence that's one thing pops
i would do i would just you know tell
tell your kids hey um i just want to
take her on the college vision they may
say dad that makes no sense okay cool
that's why i'm not asking y'all to do it
i'ma do it you know i'ma take her out
there and expose her
if we can expose our young people to
music to
hip hop videos to the latest dances then
we can expose our young people to
something educational
something informational something that
will change their life
not just make them go viral on instagram
but that can make them go viral
in life because when she comes back i
want to go to school
granddad what i got to do to come here
you need to get good grades
okay you need to focus in class you need
to be obedient to your teacher you need
to listen to your parents
and so i gave you three things that are
not really practical
money specific things uh for your dog
for your granddaughter to do these are
three things that if you and her parents
can set up and do right now
it would change the trajectory of your
uh granddaughter's future
make sense serious yes without a doubt
thank you so much i appreciate you guys
well hey
i'm gonna throw two more on yeah go
ahead do it number one i want to shout
out
terence and every grandparent
every granddad i'm gonna focus on
granddads
the fact that you were sitting down
reading books to your granddaughter
yeah i tell you what that's legacy
changing in and of itself terence
that's an investment in young people
with your most precious resource that
you can never get back
and that's your time yeah and that is
communicating to this 11 year old girl
that she has value
that she is loved she's got purpose
granddaddy reads to her man
good for you here's the other thing in
addition to the
to the anthony i've never even thought
of that and i
love this idea of putting actual
pictures into the hearts and minds of
our kids
terence i want you to raise uh to
co-raise right it sounds like you've got
a lot of influence on that young lady
i want you to let her know that she is
strong
and that she is fierce and that her
opinions
matter and that starts with sometimes
when you talk to her i want you to bend
down and look her in the eye
and say hey how did that feel
how does that make you did you like that
tell me why you liked it tell me why you
didn't
i want you to be the person that this
powerful paternal influence in her life
that teaches her
that her inner voice is strong that
teaches her that her thoughts
and opinions have value to them they
might always be true
but you're you're you're building these
blocks so that when she shows up at
whatever school
she's going to walk into every class and
know yeah my granddad found value in me
my parents found value in me
i can do hard hard stuff yeah
and that doesn't come in a classroom
that comes from people who love you
who pour into you who aren't just
throwing advice at you all day who
aren't just saying do this
saying hey tell me about this because
i'm training somebody how to think how
to how to
own themselves right yeah good for you
terence man that that may be my favorite
call of day so far yeah
it is man and i want to say this again
america i want y'all to hear me clearly
this is
anthony o'neil saying this i
i get so frustrated bro when i get on
instagram when i get on facebook and i
see
parents celebrating that their daughter
knows the latest hip-hop song
celebrating their daughter or their son
knows the latest
dance that's out there and then they
want to call me
and say hey how do i educate
my kids on this and that it's the same
thing that you're doing
you know you're teaching them you're
allowing them to learn this no stop that
get them off of instagram get them off
of facebook get them
off of youtube tell them to sit down in
front of a computer screen
and learn and look at colleges learn and
look at how to budget
since my little nephew theo he was our
first my first nephew since he could
walk and talk every time he got around
myself
every time he got around his parents
with me we talked about money christmas
last year
i was the first time i sat down and
explained to them hey
this is why your uncle put twelve
hundred dollars inside of your 529 each
one of y'all's 529
because i want you to go off to college
well what's the 529 uncle anthony
come on now they don't understand
anything i'm saying
but they're asking the question well
what is a 529
uncle anthony i have the conversation
and as they get older now they're
starting to process things
because why when they were a little kid
we started teaching them things
ahead of their time no five-year-olds
should know
some hip-hop dance like that doing it
better than the 30-year-old person but
when
when a five-year-old moves and mom
lights up and picks up the camera then
the kid gets the dopamine hit that says
that's what my value is exactly now if
they sit down
and have to listen to another boring
lecture from uncle anthony
yeah what they're going to remember is
wait a minute yeah to change futures you
plan way in advance come on man
you plan way in advance and you have
conversations with people that only want
to hear come on man
my nephew needs to know the difference
in the asset and liability my
they know the difference between a
credit card and a debit card and half of
y'all older people don't even know what
the difference is
our federal government does not know the
difference between pretty much yeah
absolutely right
listen you're everything you do
your kids are watching yeah the kids are
learning yes
tell them that education is important
tell them that they're every time
it is our responsibility to train them
up in the way that they
should go start training them the right
way american turn off tick tock
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show we're
taking your calls on life and money
let's go to jarrett in pittsburgh
pennsylvania jarrett what's going on man
hey how you doing man we're doing great
how can we help um so
i'm 19 and i have actually
i have 12 000 dollars and
no debt and also i'll be getting a tax
return plus
those stimulus checks because i didn't
receive the first ones
and then i was just wondering i can't
decide whether i should
put it towards investing
or set it aside for a business and i
also still have to follow
uh baby step three but i've been working
two jobs for six months
and plus i pick up side jobs when i can
and i've
sold all my junk so i've been in full
gazelle mode okay
jared where do you what are you doing
with your life man so you're 19 years
old
got some good savings you have no debt
but you're working two jobs like what's
the
what's the end goal like what are you
trying to land a career
are you doing something right now to see
what you want to do so you can go into
college
like talk to me 10 years down the road
where do you see yourself what are you
doing 10 years from now
um well i would say i'd like to just
um perfection what i'm doing right now
i'm remodeling bathrooms
oh okay and um awesome i'd like to
yeah i'd like to take that under my belt
for myself just to
even if i don't make a career
it's like a plan b thing so i'd like to
be an entrepreneur
but if it doesn't work out for me that
with being an entrepreneur
when you say an entrepreneur now when
you say entrepreneur bro what do you
mean like doing what you're doing now
but doing it
as an entrepreneur like you have your
own remodeling business
no i i'd like to have i have plenty of
different ideas for businesses like i'd
like
just for a small example i'd like to
have like a t-shirt company or
um just uh i thought of um
like doing like hydro dipping i'm not
sure if you know what that is
okay yeah i do know hydro dipping
wheels and cards and stuff like that
right yeah yeah
i know all about that trust me you
talking about language and i think
that's i think
everything that you've said is great
here's
here's my question i can tell you what
to do with your money right now
but when it when i specifically talk to
young people like yourself
i want to tell you what to do with your
money that will set you up to do what
you want to do tomorrow
aka the future so that's what
that's what i'm trying to hear from you
and i'm not really hearing from
hearing from you what you really want to
do so here's the very first advice i
want to give you
is i want you to sit down okay and i
want you to go to kencoleman.com go to
the ken coleman show uh
if i'm not mistaken yeah um go there i
want you to listen to ken coleman he's
going to help you really identify
what do you want to do if you want to be
an entrepreneur that's great
sounds like you're already doing stuff
in in the remodeling business
that's phenomenal i love that um
if you want to get into redoing cars and
wrapping cars and
hydro dipping cars and rails and stuff
like that's great money i just had
someone paint my wheels and
do that reminds great money over there
that's cool let's identify where do you
want to go
so what you can do right now from a
practical standpoint because it sounds
like you are not going to college
you may have to go to trade school
depending on what you do let's say if
you do the remodeling things i
want you to pick up some some trade get
some education there but it's not gonna
be a lot of money
so i will go ahead and invest this money
right now into a roth ira
that's what i would do uh go ahead and
finish your baby step three like you
said
get your three months of an emergency
fund and because you
you're really not really secure in your
job just yet
i will go ahead and get six months so
that way you have a
good solid savings account and then take
the stimulus check
going ahead jump on the phone with a
smart vessel pro tell them hey i got
about a couple of grand i want to invest
into a roth ira
go ahead and open that up and start
putting money into that as early as um
as you possibly can uh but the key thing
i think for you
is not really what you're doing with
your money now john i think he really
needs to define
where is he going uh in the future
because it sounds like he's just out
there just trying a bunch of things with
no solid gameplay
and the challenge with somebody like him
who's good at something
yeah is that you may be really good at
remodeling bathrooms
you may not be great at running a
remodeling business yes without some new
tools without a lot of wisdom and a lot
of
failures and skin needs and so i love
what you're talking about
man really map out yeah what do you want
to do and how do you want to do it
that's absolutely man all right let's go
to uh michelle
in eugene oregon michelle what's going
on
hey there so thank you so much for your
time i appreciate it
you bet thanks for calling what's up
yeah i'm so happy to be here so i'm 54
years old and have spent
over the last five years making really
bad decisions
um i lost a job where i was making
almost a hundred thousand dollars a year
um spent about two years looking for a
job unfortunately i
thought it was a good idea to use my
retirement to get me through
okay so now i'm looking at covid i left
my job last year
finally got a new one but i am making
half of what i was previously so
so you're making about 50 000 right now
right yeah
yeah and um so that hurts
you know by the time i pay off all the
bills every month i
have a couple hundred in my pocket for
necessities
okay um i have about five thousand
dollars in savings
okay and i got forty two thousand
dollars in credit card debt
forty two thousand dollars in credit
card debt
i know i told you i made some mistakes
okay
um i have 60 000 in student loans
50 000 okay 60 okay
yeah and that i shouldn't have had
because when
i was working my employer paid for my
education
and my son was starting college at the
same time
so i didn't want him to be in debt and i
assumed that i was going to forever be
making this much money could afford
to take out the loans what are the debt
do you have do you have you have any car
loans
no no just my home just your home okay
cool so
right now so right now you're in 102 000
in consumer debt plus another hundred
plus thousand dollars on your mortgage
right
yeah okay and you're making fifty
thousand dollars a year
yeah okay we have a shovel problem
i do i have we have we have we have an
income
problem okay yeah um what you have to do
right now
michelle is to really really figure out
what can we do
um you know um
right now
i want to say go get go get another job
um i want to say
figure out how right now how to get two
jobs to get your your
your income up uh but then i also want
to tell you hey
you need to check out our career expert
because we need to get your income back
up to a hundred thousand dollars
so this way you can attack your credit
card debt followed by your student loans
um and and uh real quickly because we're
about to come to the end of the show um
are you supporting your son financially
in any way right now
yeah okay cool great so right now here's
your theme michelle what you need to be
focusing on
is number one in the meantime go ahead
and get you a
part-time job that you can do on the
side to get your income up
all of that money from your part-time
job you don't have time to be eating out
you don't have time to be taking your
son out nowhere nice
you need to be focusing right now on how
to get out of debt and paul's
all investing okay i want you to pause
your investing i know you're saying hey
i'm i'm 50 something years old i need to
invest no we need to invest into you
getting out of debt
that's right okay that's the main thing
so
that's that's my main thing well and
here's the other thing michelle you
started this call
talking about all the mistakes you made
yeah you spoke
throughout the call as you were rattling
off a rap sheet
why you have a life sentence and listen
you cannot continue to drag your
past around with you and expect to get
anywhere down the road very far so as of
today you've announced you if
you have uh called in and confessed to
america to millions you did stupid stuff
congratulations you're gonna have to get
in line we all have we've done stupid
stuff in relationships we've done stupid
stuff with our money we've done stupid
stuff at jobs
all of us have every listener on this
show has done stupid stuff
you're not by yourself on this michelle
you have to put that crap
down and then be about moving forward
yeah so i don't want you to talk about
your mistakes anymore i want you to
to revel in them and roll around and
collect them because that's called shame
move on with them put them down and go
be about solving this problem with
another job and another job
and make this thing go this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit daveramsey.com
show and register we would love for you
to come to nashville and tell your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation
about your money and your life i am john
deloney joined here
by best-selling author host of the table
with anthony o'neal
mr anthony o'neill himself and we're
taking your calls on life
and money give us a shout at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
let's go right to the phones let's go to
taylor in memphis tennessee
taylor what's up hey how's it going guys
good to talk to you
you too man what's going on how are you
well
me and my wife um have a little bit of a
difference and and you get to be the
deciding vote
um we uh we own our house outright
um so no payments we own both of our
vehicles we have
um a little over a million dollars
invested we're doing
real good we've worked through dave
ramsey's
total money makeover years ago and it's
wonderful
okay here's the deal i'm a pilot and i
would like to take out some of the money
from our investments and buy me a
private plane
i've done the math it's actually cheaper
than renting a plane and stuff like that
my wife is hesitant partially because
it's such a big outlay all at once and
we've never had that kind of money
before
she thinks i should keep renting she's
not the numbers
one i'm the numbers one and i'm just
wondering
i know dave has said if you've got a
million dollars buy the new car
this is a little pricier than a new car
i'm just looking for some advice
how much is the plan going to cost you
man i have capped out my budget at 100
000 for the plane i'm only going to look
at stuff that's under 100 000.
okay and that's for the cost of the plan
how much is the plan going to cost you
taylor um
i don't have the numbers right in front
of me insurance believe it or not is
ridiculously cheap it's cheaper than car
insurance the biggest expense on a
yearly basis
is the the annual inspection and that
fluctuates it can be as
as low as two or three thousand or as
high as 12 000 depending on if you've
got to have work done
cool what about storage storage fees
gas yeah i mean they have have you all
sat down and said all right what is his
plan going to cost me
uh because i have several people who own
planes but
uh they all say that the the expensive
part
is not behind the plane up front the
expensive part is the maintenance uh
throughout the years of owning the plane
so what is that fee
a year for you yeah that is the
expensive part and again like i said i
don't have my spreadsheet right in front
of me i did do the math though
and i worked out that if i fly more than
i think it's 42 hours a year
even including maintenance costs it's
cheaper to own than to rent
um and so of course you know obviously
the more you fly the cheaper it is per
hour like i said i don't have all those
numbers right in front of me but
taylor i'm not in our budget i don't
have a plane so
help me with this is a plane similarly a
depreciating
asset like a car
not really i mean i guess over time they
do depreciate but it's
very very slow i mean you're well
you can you can easily go out and buy a
plane right now from the early 60s
and it's still you're paying you know a
hundred thousand dollars or
just slightly under for a plane that's
40 or 50 years old
now of course new ones get far more
expensive but they do hold their value
fairly well
cool so uh what's your household income
real quick uh taylor
um probably uh around 70. i'm a pastor
and my wife is a counselor i mean we
don't make a ton of money but we
inherited
we inherited well and have it invested
okay so about 70 000
a year and you want to go buy
a plane that i'm thinking maintenance is
going to run you about 20 to 25 thousand
dollars a year
just to maintain that's probably on the
high side for maintenance
yeah but this would this would come out
of investment
but listen to me taylor um your
maintenance is not going to come out of
investments you can't
you invest it so you can retire off of
that income
eventually and so if you go buy the
plane the only way you're going to pull
out from investments is if
if it's not covered up on the underneath
the retirement situation so if you go
pull money from a stocks
i don't have a problem with that i think
my biggest problem is and my biggest
concern
is you only make 70 000 a year but
you're going
to encounter on a high end
maybe twenty five thousand dollars a
year maintenance uh my vote is no table
uh that that's that's my vote and mine
is
is not mathematical it's purely
psychological
meaning it may cost you more money
down the road to rent
but the ability to hand the keys to
somebody else and go home and they've
got to deal with new tires and gas and
that one
weird gauge and the fluctuations in this
and that
there's a psychological piece to that
that making seven yeah
if you look at it this way you're buying
a hundred thousand dollar toy
with a fifteen thousand to twenty
thousand dollar your price tag
to operate yeah against yeah against
your salary it's a lot man there's
something to be said for handing the
keys back and i know you've done the
math and i can hear it in your voice he
really wants
oh you want a plane so bad but it's not
wise
to financially make 70 thousand dollars
a year
and then you go from and i get it here
he's debt-free he has you know a million
dollars in in
investments that's great but here's the
thing it's like man
do you really want to go into retirement
years with the 25 000
bill in your hand and a year yeah a year
and it's like
do you really want to do that so i'm
saying no
um because i'm just thinking of the
numbers
it doesn't make sense now if you was
telling me you bring in a half a million
dollars a year and
you know your mainstream will be twenty
five thousand dollars and you're you're
debt-free 100
and you've got a million dollars in
assets yeah that's okay go do it
no but your income is kind of low and
i'm scared because i'm like
i don't know man that's tight that's
tight something could come up
and i don't want you to have to go to
your investments until you are retiring
and then my goal is you're living off of
the interest
of your investments you're not pulling
from your investment
right that's my goal when it comes to
retirement and
this happens with planes it happens with
ranches
it happens with big fancy boats yeah it
happens with anything that
we fall in love with it's a really a big
toy absolutely and a ranch can be a
really big toy
right yeah and a boat and what whatever
that looks like man
and i also have this feeling in my
stomach we just dashed this poor man's
dreams
taylor to don't tell your wife don't do
the happy dance you heard it in his
heart he really wants this airplane
and he can possibly get it down the road
that's right we don't know
well he's got to earn some more money
right yeah he needs to earn some more
money so that way he has some cushion
uh for the maintenance because again
that's 70 000
gross so we're not talking about net
right you know so i mean that's just
that could be
close to half of his income is going
towards his plane and i just have
ha i'm always about risk and i never
want to leverage
my family's finances on a toy yeah right
um that risk is so so so high
all right you ever thought about owning
a jet yeah i thought about it
and no i've never even considered that
yeah i was about to say
i mean uh i dream about owning
rolls-royce one day
like when i'm 50 60 years old but a jet
don't win the maintenance one day i'm
gonna have a car that was made
in the 2010 decade that's my goal
i'm gonna keep working hard i'm gonna
get there anthony it's gonna be a 2015.
why you are the you are the so
soft moderate guy i'm the loud
flamboyant guy but hey you know what
we're both doing it dead free
hey whatever works for you it is what it
is this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people uh you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had
chm chm saved our life same document
financial life
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance
but it is a budget-friendly option and
the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
[Music]
lions.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means
even if you mismeasure or pick the wrong
color they'll remake your blinds for
free
you get free samples free shipping with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more
use promo code ramsey to get the best
deal rules and restrictions apply
today's question comes from clayton in
san bernardino clayton writes
i'm a high school senior with straight
a's way to go clayton
my stepfather refuses to let me get a
job so i can save for college
instead he makes me work at his business
without pay
man every time these blinds.com
questions get my blood pressure all
up my only option to pay for college is
going into debt and i don't want that
i'm trying to get as many scholarships
as possible as well as financial aid
from fafsa
but i'm scared it won't cover my cost
what do i do
anthony i got all kinds of feelings on
this one what do you think
my stepfather refuses to let me get a
job so i can save for
college instead he makes me work at his
business without pay
i'm going to be hoping that his father
is not paying him today
but he's working for pay in the future
it sounds like he's got a family
business and i expect your butt to be at
work tomorrow
helping fill in the blank right hoping
do oil changes help wash windows up
whatever it's against the law right yeah
and i really can't answer this question
man because it's like i wouldn't believe
that the parents have the best
intent for their son and that they're
saying hey we're going to cover you
we're going to have the conversation
and i'm i'm wondering if clayton is
thinking hey
i'm not my parents are not going to help
me get into school right and so for me
yes we're not going to take out any debt
no we're not going to do that but if i'm
you men i'm having a serious
conversation with mom
and with that like hey i have no problem
working with the family business
but hey what about my life like how are
we going to provide for college do you
all have a game plan
can we talk about my future um i'm not
getting paid here
are you all saving this money to go
towards my college
like i'm literally sitting down and i'm
having a conversation
uh with my parents on the flip side for
the parents listening
in on this remember it's a two-way
street
you know it is your responsibility to
guide
your your kids uh in the way that they
should go so have a conversation with
them and let them know hey
we're going to help you hey here's our
game plan hey
this is what we need from you um so i
really can't
i really can't tell him to do anything
outside of talk to your parents
and get a clear path of what they can do
and what they cannot do
then from there give us a call back on
the show and we can give you some better
advice
and i'll i'll read between a couple of
lines here
it says my only option to pay for
college is going into debt and i don't
want that
then don't that's not your only option
it may mean that if let's say this plays
out anthony let's say that dad
um is only going to let you is going to
look you and say i don't care what you
do for college that's not my problem my
problem is right now with your butt back
in there
washing dishes or whatever this this job
is yeah
that doesn't mean your only option
paying for college going to debt that
means you may not be able to go to
stanford that means you may have to go
to local community college you may have
to get four jobs
when you get out of school that does not
mean just because somebody
is treating you unfairly your response
is to do something that's going to harm
your future
it's not that's not how that works okay
i know you're trying to get as many
scholarships as possible that's
awesome good for you it might not cover
your costs you may have to work you may
have to put off college for a year you
may have to do
any number of other things other than
shackle yourself to
college debt yeah and here's the other
thing
it's against the law what he's doing but
if you're a high school senior
and this is not a safe situation
unfortunately there is
abusive parents there are um just
parents that are garbage
and it may be a clayton that you got to
ride this out
you're living under their roof as a high
school senior the moment you graduate
you go get your own place and you're out
of there
you may have to ride this out and i
don't like giving that advice
but there's kids that uh unfortunately
under the legal guardianship of their
parents
and there's there's safety issues there
if you are not safe
if your father stepfather is continuing
to abuse your rights as a human being
and force you to work for free
to the detriment of your future let
somebody at your school know
let's let your guidance counselor know
they'll help you walk through the the
proper authority channels
uh the proper channels with the
authorities but this is something this
is a mess
i ain't read into that like that you
didn't see i didn't i think we're seeing
this two different ways
oh yeah i know we are that's why i'm
glad we are yeah i mean i am glad
i'm glad too i mean because my mother
made me work
for free for free okay but
also my parents also made sure i went to
school
they also made sure that i was eating at
home they also made sure that i
i had what i needed and sometimes had
what i wanted
but when i would go and open up my mom's
daycare and when i would come
out after school and help her out to
daycare my mom may never give me no
check
right but it wasn't abuse it was my mom
and dad were teaching me how to work
while they were also providing and
making sure that i was taken care of so
it could be both ways so i like what you
say
if it is in my experiences working with
so many college kids over the years has
been
man they come into your office and shut
the door and they let you know my
parents treated me like this
all right and you get lots of those yeah
yeah i'm with you and so that's why i
love
like a broad perspective here if this is
not a safe place reach out to your
guidance counselor man
if your dad's just a jerk man you may
have to ride this out for five more
months
or if it's like anthony's situation go
open the daycare yeah
and they're gonna help you out but it
starts with a conversation right
absolutely
um and it runs the gamut there from all
different kinds of experiences
um man we'll be rooting for you clayton
yeah the end of the day
just because somebody's holding you up
on this end doesn't mean you got to go
do something
dumb on your end right don't right don't
don't
all right let's take a call let's go to
nicole in minneapolis nicole what's
going on
hi gentlemen thanks for taking my call
you bet what's up
um i'm just going to see if i should pay
off my car loan i have about 4 300
left on that and i have about six
thousand this
evening and i'm just wanting to know i
just kind of started listening to dave
ramsey's
show as well as looking into his baby
steps
and i'm just kind of going indicted yeah
yeah um what other debt do you have
nicole
so i have student loan debts but i'm
currently still in school full-time
okay so i will not have to start paying
those back until next year
um as i'm done this summer how much
how much longer do you have oh this
summer you're done yeah
okay so have you already paid for the
rest of the semester
um yes this semester is taken care of
next month okay cool are you are you
doing student loans with next semester
yes but i'm beginning now i'll still
have to pay about two grand out of
pocket
but i'm currently competing with 200
every month to my savings okay real
quick um how much is next semester
with the out-of-pocket or with the
student loans combined uh
the total i would say maybe
3 500. okay cool i want you to pay cash
for next semester
take the six thousand dollars and put
thirty five hundred dollars towards
semester studies
that way you don't borrow any more money
okay then
you take the rest of the money you put
that towards your car
leave a thousand dollars in your
emergency fund uh but right now i want
you to go ahead and pay
cash for next semester so that way
you're not borrowing no more money
okay that's the number one priority then
after you graduate um college and you
get done with college
take the rest of your money put that
towards your 4 300
card okay um and then immediately once
you get your job
once you go ahead and just do the debt
snowballs which the the least one will
be your car
then you put your student loans behind
that and start attacking it from there
uh but right now don't worry about
paying off your car i want you to
to go in ahead and prevent yourself from
taking out more student loans because
long term
that interest rate will kill you and i
don't want you to do that if you don't
have to so pay cash next semester
and you'll be straight it's kind of like
um
i'm trying to i'm trying to think of a
good analogy here it's like trying to
eat
soup with a hole in your spoon right
right right if you are paying off this
debt while turning around taking more
debt on behind you right
right right right at some point you got
to just call it stop it say no more debt
yeah
if you want to get out of debt you have
to stop getting into that
if you want to say that again that's
like a prophetic statement i'm serious
it's so deep man i mean god just gave it
to me if you
want to get out of debt stop
getting into debt okay if i had a
xylophone i would just
listen i would let it rip right now
listen man if i wasn't if i was in
church
i'm not gonna say that stop getting into
dead
i love it nicole hey we're so glad
you're with us nicole
a few months from now you're gonna have
a you're gonna be out of college
you're gonna start paying your stuff
back and you are gonna walk a life
a free woman this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two
five we're taking your calls on life and
money let's go to adriana in
phoenix arizona adriana what's going on
[Music]
hi um so i'm calling because me and my
husband we want to purchase a house and
this would technically be our first
house
we don't want to set ourselves up for
failure but we also don't know
um this is our first time we don't know
where to start what's
good for us what's not good for us it's
a good time for us to try
um you know we just don't we just don't
know
all right uh talking to the phone there
um are you outside with the wind
yeah all right get somewhere where you
can where we can hear you where the
wind's not on you
and then ask your question again so
y'all are about to buy your first house
yes we want to buy our first house but
we don't know
where to start we don't know if it's a
good
decision right now with the market we
don't know where to turn
you know like i said it's just it's our
first time so we don't know
what to expect or anything like that all
right you've got the expert sitting
right next to me
yeah um so give me a little bit of your
financials what do you all make a year
right now currently um between
60 and 70 000 a year okay so we got in
between 60 and 70 k
and do you have any debt i can't
remember if you said that i was hard
hearing
um we just recently paid off all of our
debt okay so yeah
for you congratulations okay cool how
much do you have in your savings
uh we have about 15 000.
okay so we got 15k now is that a good
full three to six months
um yeah i would say so what would you
say it is
um well monthly we only
we only um our monthly bills equals
2500. okay
all right sounds good all right so
um i think that you all are in a great
place to start
uh the process of um
[Music]
uh the home process so if your monthly
expenses are running about 2500
this means that you're going to need
about 7 500 so if i was you i would just
go ahead and make that a flat
10k into your emergency fund that you do
not touch so this leaves you with 5 000
in your savings account all right i see
that you're in arizona so you all can
get a beautiful home
in in arizona for about 200 000 am i
correct
yeah yeah so for for a 200 000
home in arizona which will be beautiful
you only need
forty thousand dollars to put down um on
your down payment to get
to get into a conventional loan with no
pmi and so
um i'm going to say from right there
that would be it about we teach
make sure that your mortgage payment is
is 25
less is gonna be your mortgage payment
and homeowners insurance and hoas if
possible
so if you do this thing correctly this
means that your payment shouldn't be no
more than 1250
of your actual take-home pay so this
would be 250
should be your your max on your mortgage
all right
so i'm saying for you all right now go
into baby step
3b where number one is you're gonna save
a thousand dollar emergency fund you
already did baby step number two
you paid off all your debt and you've
already done baby set number three by
having you know 15k in your savings
account you only need 10
000. now 3b is when we work to save
10 to 20 of uh
your money so you can have for a down
payment on your mortgage
so i would spend the rest of this year
just getting to about twenty thousand
dollars
in your account once you do that go get
you a home
okay all right so that's the very first
step now the second step is once you get
your 20 000
i want you to call churchill mortgage um
and tell them hey anthony and john from
ramsey solutions sent me to you all we
are looking to purchase a home we don't
have any debt but we do have twenty
thousand dollars that we can put down
and worst case scenario if you find a
great home and you can put down ten
thousand dollars go ahead and do that
that's fine too um
but call churchill mortgage tell them
hey you want to get pre-qualified this
is my budget
i'm not going past this here's the money
and they'll take good care of you all
right
okay all right sounds good hey i love it
and then one final thing i want you to
get with an elp
that's going to help you navigate the
home buying market there yes
right yes so according to the united
states census bureau nearly 1 in 10
people relocated last year and that was
in 2020
and that means this year everybody's
buckling down there's a good chance you
or someone you know is gonna be planning
a big move
now i know it feels like there are a
thousand unknowns you're juggling when
you're relocating
but you cannot lose focus of one of your
most important personal and financial
factors in your move
your housing right just like we're
talking about man they get so excited
they've done everything right
and then they're going to fall in love
with that one house and they overpay
they may not know in this particular
neighborhood it's like this versus it
get an endorsed local provider right i
recommend hiring a quality real estate
agent like one of our endorsed local
providers or elps
to help you find the right home in your
city anthony used one
i used one this is what we do here this
isn't just something we pop off at the
mouth about this is what we
trust our families and our own home
buying experiences with absolutely they
are top performing experts in their
local market and have
years of experience helping folks just
like you make successful moves yeah
it's easy to get instantly connected
with an elp agent right now just text
house
to eight nine to talk with a ramsey
trusted agent about how they can help
you with your relocation
that's house two three three seven eight
nine all right let's go to esmeralda out
in santa barbara esmerelda what's going
on
hi hi hi um
so my question is my husband and i own
a couple of properties our main home um
which has the granny you need and we
have a little airbnb running out of it
and a second unit that's a duplex
um my husband wants to hold on to it but
our
mortgage insurance and utilities
have left us kind of not making any
money on it
and the rental market in our area has
boomed so um i spoke to a realtor
and my um the suggested price
that they say we could get for it is
about 815 000
um how much do you have we bought it for
360 and we owe about 290.
you can sell it for how much again eight
hundred and fifteen
thousand okay well what's the question i
would have sold that yesterday
so the question well the 815 i'm sorry
is
if i add a third unit to the property
oh so you got to invest money into it to
get the 815. how much money do you need
to invest
to get that money how much would it cost
you 27 000. 27.
okay all right well let me ask you this
question
why did you all get into the rental
property did you get into it for the
equity and long-term play
or did you get into it to generate
monthly
income um
i my interpretation of it
this is where my husband and i did work
he wanted the monthly
income and i wanted to hold it for a
little bit and sell it when it was more
valuable
yeah um he is under
kind of the guideline that if we add
that third unit
because it makes sense to add it for
such a low cost
um he wants to keep it um
i would like to take that money and pay
off our home
um your personal living yes yeah i like
that idea
all day every day including sunday i
love that idea
i'm tr because we're about to go to
break um
here's my thing i think you two need to
sit down you have some great options
i'm i'm if i'm in your shoes if i'm your
husband i'm sitting down asking
ourselves okay
how can we pay off our personal home and
keep that property and see if we can get
that thing to a million dollars
and then sell it because you're right
around the corner from it so we can keep
it for
another five years see if we can get it
appraised for 900 plus thousand dollars
and it's in this you know right around
150 000 on it that's owed
i i'm gonna keep that money because
that's that's good money especially the
twenty seven thousand dollar investment
so this one right here ma'am i i think
you and your husband got to sit down and
talk
you're debt-free you guys got some good
money set aside figure it out
i mean how can we pay off our home for
sure
and then also how can we keep this here
to possibly gain more equity
and then sell it and then you're sitting
on six seven hundred thousand dollars in
your pocket
and do not take out a home equity loan
do not to build that third unit do not
do it don't touch it if you don't have
twenty seven thousand dollars in cash
if you do i'm gonna come out of this
show and i'm gonna come get you this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
james 1 12.
blessed is the one who perseveres under
trial because having stood the test
that person will receive the crown of
life that the lord has promised to those
who love him
thomas edison said the most certain way
to succeed
is always to try just one more time
try just one more time and speaking of
trying
just one more time and then man you hit
one out of the park
the table with anthony o'neil your
youtube show has just lost its
ever loving mind podcast is
up and to the right tell us what's going
on
man you know one of the things that i
love about the table
and what you know our team is doing over
there with the ao brand is
we're really understanding that this
younger generation of 18
between 18 and 34 really want that real
relevant
and relatable and authentic uh
conversation you know um the language
over there is a little different
you know the the community over there is
a little different um the little tone
and philip
is a little different um and we're just
having that real conversation about
money you know we
we are having a real conversation about
how our relationships are impacting some
of the decisions
uh that we're making that's impacting
our money that's impacting us and
preventing us from actually building
uh wealth i'm making
the word retirement sexy in the younger
generation
generation um and and it's not a safe
show you know you're going to come over
there you're going to get my raw
authentic opinion um you're going to get
some practical information that would
change your life
and you're going to hear some amazing
stories of young people
from all walks of life all ages
especially around 18 to 34. for an
example i have a show coming up
with a couple man i can't wait john
you're gonna love this one uh this is
why everyone needs to go subscribe to my
channel
today um i have a young guy coming up
um him and his wife started off on food
stamps he's 33 years old
and him and his wife now generate 10
million dollars a year
in revenue wow 10 at 33 debt free
uh they just made it onto the forbes
list last month they paid
cash uh for a strip mall
cash at 33 they didn't finance nothing
they didn't they didn't go and borrow no
money no they paid cash
and brother when i say we we we walked
that walk bro we talked that talk on the
show
um like i said the language is different
it's not bad but it's just it's just a
different type of language for a younger
audience
and i mean bro i left that show i left
my own show
encouraged inspired um and those are the
kind of conversations that that i
really love that we're having at the
table and i'm so grateful for our team
you know we have chris wright over there
producing the show right now
then i have my my business manager brand
leader uh
alex uh then and then you know taylor
and her team just made me an amazing
studio
so let me let me get into this so i
think challenges that
as as a parent i have yeah is i
remember what it's like being 11 right
and i
pick up and transpose my life onto my
current 11 year old son
right right right right right and some
wisdom is timeless
some values are timeless right and in
other ways
life's just different absolutely they do
pe different they teach
you know as neighbor gotsi mentioned
that they teach math different now
right what would you tell a parent
driving down the road right now
who's got a 22 year old a 29 year old
it's easy to remember when i was 22 i
was filling the blank when i was 29 i
remember that
what what are some things you're hearing
like over and over some common themes
that are rising up from 25 year olds and
29 year olds
as they're trying to navigate this just
chaotic world that we live in right now
one of the things i tell parents all the
time not even just parents grandparents
and older people when when they come to
me complaining what young people just
don't listen well listen
the message doesn't change it's the
method of how we deliver the message
that needs to change a little bit you
know one of the things i love
what we're doing here at ramsey is
you're able to reach people that i'm not
able to reach
dave is able to reach people that i'm
not able to reach i'm able to reach
people that
you know some people here may not be
able to reach we're not talking
different messages
we're changing up the method of how we
deliver it and so one of the common
things i'm hearing from young people is
i don't want to hear about retirement
that's for old people
well it's not for old people and so what
i'm doing i'm flipping it saying
retirement is just
building wealth and wealth is going to
help you
live longer and enjoy your life whenever
you decide not to work
the message is not changing from dave
and myself from rachel myself on myself
on the money side i'm just changing up
the method on how i deliver the content
someone if parents are driving right now
you're saying man my daughter just won't
listen i want to go to college debt free
cool put her on to my content get her
over to my show
because she's going to get the same
message that you're getting from the
ramsay show
but she's going to get it in a way that
is more appealing and that is more
understanding
to her in her age bracket one of the
things i tell young people especially
right now being a former youth pastor
uh and i tell youth pastor this you
never want to talk to a 11th grader like
an 11th grader you want to talk to 11th
grader like like he or she is a freshman
in college
because they look up to the college age
middle schoolers don't want to be
treated like middle schoolers they want
to be treated like high schoolers so
level up when you're talking
level up when you're talking to them
never go way down to the level because
they
they don't feel respected they don't
feel important no when you treat
a uh eighth grader like a rising 10th
grader like oh
yes and so it's like for me um that's
why for me all of my mentors are older
than me they're in their 50s they're in
their 60s why because
i want the wisdom that they have because
one day i want to be like dave ramsey
one day i want to be like bishop td
jakes
one day i want to be like dr tony evans
one day i want to be like mark cuban
so i'm looking older i'm getting my
information from someone older but not
too much older than me and so on at the
table man we're simply just
really um i'm staying in tune with the
culture i'm staying in tune with
what is the world saying about wealth
and about you know stuff like that
and i'm teaching them man and this is
the truth
um like you know i just recently
purchased my car and i put it on my
instagram and i put on my youtube some
people said well why'd you say that
but let me tell you why young people are
looking at these celebrities
and saying i want that car i want that
house but they're looking at them and
they're not understanding
that these people are financing it
they're putting on lease they're not
paying their bills so they can look a
certain kind of way
it's not real and what i'm trying to
show them is like hey we can get our
dreams
we can get we can go after everything
that we want but there is a way to do it
and we got to have a solid foundation
and so for me and my brand
i want to show them hey i waited six
years so i can save for this car i'm
waiting another three years so i can
build my dream house i
waited to do this because i went to make
sure i was out of debt i want to make
sure i had a fully funded emergency fund
i want to make sure when i purchased my
home i wasn't
house broke i was a house poor so
that's what we're doing over in my show
man i would love too much go to
youtube.com
and subscribe to at the table with
the table with anthony o'neal yes
awesome all right let's go to uh
yeah what's up real quick get let's get
a phone call let's go to noelle in
miami florida what's going on how are we
doing
hey guys how are you doing good how can
we help i had uh
i called dave um two years back uh back
in 2014 about paying off a student loan
and i did that and then called back
again about saving up you know for a
house
and i started saving emergency fund and
started putting money into
uh you know more money in the 401k and
same courthouse so basically
uh 3b which i'm still in 3b
it's like many beats and along the way
along the path
i was got engaged we could not get on
the same path
in terms of the finances broke up and
about 18 months
got back together and then got engaged
and i was
compromising in some areas but they
really didn't want to
and then ended up you know things just
you know didn't work out
and broke the engagement off uh hey hey
well we're sliding right up against the
clock let's get right to your question
um i've got 155 000 saved up towards
your house
and housing is very expensive and so
i've the whole time since i've been
saving
i thought i was in the three to five
year window of either investing or just
saving cash
and so i want to know you know should i
be
stopping the cash and putting into a
mutual fund or putting
some into a mutual fund now not you know
necessarily i can't you know really
afford a house based upon a 25
uh you know take home pay in the area
where i work
so just trying to see some guidance on
continue to save for the house so listen
man uh sorry i had to cut you off so
quick but here's the thing
if you're going to buy the house within
the next three to five years keep it in
a money market account
so you can put it uh towards the house
if not go ahead and put it into a mutual
fund
so that way you can get a little bit
more interest for it if you're gonna do
it
after five years from now all right so
sorry i had to cut you off bro i want to
thank james childs and kelly daniel for
another great show anthony hey john love
you man
love you too ladies and gentlemen this
has been the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you